how did this rebel spy become the
self-sacrificing hero we met in star
wars rogue one and was this prequel
series following cassie and andor really
renewed for a second season before the
first season even comes out here's what
you need to know before watching andor
season 1.
so far the only footage that's been
revealed from andor comes from the
show's first teaser trailer while
there's little dialogue and even less in
the form of plot details the trailer
does give a pretty good impression of
the overall tone of the show and it's
pretty grim fans of rogue one will know
it's one of the darkest star wars
stories to date andor definitely seems
to be pulling from that legacy and the
teaser shows the abject terror and
torment inflicted on regular galactic
citizens by the empire the andor teaser
covers a lot of ground there are shots
of a few different planets facing down
imperial invasion glimpses of mon mothma
navigating dangerous political
situations in the imperial senate and of
course some exciting action moments
featuring andor himself overall the
footage emphasizes the human aspect of
the series a story that seems to really
be focusing on how life under an
oppressive regime impacts the lives of
ordinary people and drives them to
radicalization i've been in this fight
since i was 6 years old if andor dives
fully into these deep dramatic waters
the result could be the best star wars
series yet star wars rebels told plenty
of its own stories in the same era but
with a massive budget and the permission
to be more mature and or could bring a
whole new level of intensity to the
galactic civil war
given how long rogue one has been out
it's not exactly a spoiler that cassie
and andor like most of that film's
characters meets his end by the time
credits roll his noble sacrifice helps
the rebellion acquire the death star
plans making luke skywalker's radon and
destruction of the battle station
possible in star wars a new hope if the
rebels have obtained a complete
technical readout of this station it is
possible however unlikely that they
might find a weakness and with that in
mind and or will be more of an origin
story for cassium a tale that shows the
brutality of imperial rule through the
lens of his radicalization in a 2022
interview with vanity fair diego luna
and series creator tony gilroy confirmed
that andor season 1 will begin five
years prior to the events of rogue one
following cassian from the destruction
of his home planet through his early
involvement with the rebel alliance luna
told vanity fair it's a journey of a
migrant that feeling of having to move
is behind this story very profoundly in
the same vanity fair interview gilroy
revealed that genevieve o'reilly's mon
mothma a character first introduced in
return of the jedi will also play a huge
role in the story as one of the key
leaders of the rebel alliance from its
early days to the end of the war she's
certainly an interesting character to
include and it should be interesting to
watch her grow into the leader scene in
the original trilogy
obviously diego luna is the main star of
andor as his character's name is
literally the title of the show from
what's been revealed so far it seems
that genevieve o'reilly will have the
next largest role in the series with her
version of mon mothma serving as a kind
of counterpoint to cassie o'reilly first
played the character originated by
caroline blakiston in revenge of the
sith and she has since reprised the role
in both rogue one and as a voice actor
for star wars rebels
in addition to the two leads a number of
other notable actors have been announced
for the show many in undisclosed roles
veteran actor stellen skarsgard will
play a new character named luthen and
andrea orhona will play an as yet
unnamed character the rest of the
announced cast includes denise guff kyle
soler and fiona shaw in his vanity fair
interview gilroy said that his scripts
include 211 speaking parts and probably
75 people in there who really matter
teasing a massive ensemble cast when all
was said done
disney has confirmed that andor will
premiere on disney plus on august 31
2022 kicking off what will presumably be
a weekly release schedule akin to the
streamer's previous star wars and mcu
shows the show was originally meant for
a 2021 release but kobe 19 induced
delays caused the series to be pushed
back by the time it premieres and or
will be disney's fourth live action star
wars streaming series following the
mandalorian the book of boba fetts and
obi-wan kenobi however it also won't be
the last star wars show to debut on the
platform in 2022 season 2 of the
animated series star wars the bad batch
which follows a team of renegade clones
in the wake of order 66 is set to
premiere on september 28th that date
should fall in the middle of andor
season 1 meaning the two shows will air
simultaneously hollywood veteran tony
gilroy serves as creator and showrunner
on andor which should give fans of rogue
one reason to be optimistic gilroy
served as a screenwriter on the original
film so he's definitely familiar with
the cassian andor character however he's
probably better known as the writer of
the first four porn movies and is the
writer and director of michael clayton
for which he was nominated for two
academy awards in 2008 other writers on
andor include gilroy's brother and
frequent collaborator dan stephen schiff
who wrote several episodes of the
americans and beau willemon a showrunner
and writer on house of cards while
lucasfilm president kathleen kennedy
will serve as an executive producer
other recent star wars reliables like
john fabro and dave filoni aren't
involved in andor in addition to his
starring role diego luna also serves as
an executive producer
in a 2022 interview with empire and or
showrunner tony gilroy confirmed that
season 1 would consist of 12 episodes
that's potentially great news for fans
as it's the longest episode count in a
single season of any live-action star
wars show to date to compare each season
of the mandalorian so far has consisted
of eight episodes the book of boba fett
ran for just seven episodes and obi-wan
kenobi wrapped up after only six the
higher episode count will hopefully give
andor time to develop its many
characters but it could also be an
opportunity for the series to slow down
a bit and really build out the world of
the imperial era because the series will
be mostly free of ties to the
pre-existing canon it has the
opportunity to really flesh out new
corners of the star wars universe and
show previously unseen effects of
palpatine's tyrannical rule
while it might be premature to presume
the quality of andor at such an early
stage fans may still enjoy learning that
preparation for season 2 is already in
the works speaking with vanity fair in
2022 showrunner tony gilroy confirmed
that andor season 2 is on the way but it
sounds like the series may cap out at
just two installments he told vanity
fair it is the second season but it's
really for me the second half of the
novel the first season is about him
becoming a revolutionary and the second
12 episodes take him into rogue one that
quote would seem to confirm that andor
season 2 will be the same length as
season 1 making the full show a beefy 24
episodes because the titular protagonist
is already known there's a lot of
interesting room in there to explore
cassian's journey if done right the show
could even make rogue one better in
retrospect fleshing out cassian's
motivations and giving his final mission
even more emotional weight
and or begins five years before the
events of rogue one and according to
tony gilroy most of the time will be
covered over the course of season two
not season one the showrunner explained
in a 2022 interview with empire that
directors worked in blocks of three
episodes meaning season one was four
blocks of three episodes each when the
same filming structure was adopted for
season two the team decided to change up
the flow of time a bit using each block
to represent a year in other words and
or season one will take place over the
course of roughly one year slowly
setting the stage for cassian's prolific
career as a rebel spy and season two
will speed things up by jumping forward
about a year every few episodes this
asymmetrical structure could give the
two seasons a wildly different sense of
pace which will hopefully keep things
feeling fresh there's also an implicit
rise in momentum in the season 2
structure which builds naturally towards
cassian's ultimate sacrifice in rogue
one i had orders
orders that i disobeyed
but you wouldn't understand
with andor being set five years before
the events of rogue one a lot of what
occurs will happen at the same time as
the events of star wars rebels however
due to how divided the rebellion is at
this stage in the star wars timeline
there won't necessarily be a ton of
overlap with the animated series
especially since it's targeted at a much
younger demographic however rebels does
give some good clues about what the
state of the universe will be like in
andor since scenes have been confirmed
in the imperial senate high-ranking
officers of palpatine's government and
military force could play important
roles in the story this means that andor
could finally be the show to bring grand
admiral thrawn to lime action as he was
very active in the years leading up to
star wars a new hope though he hasn't
been confirmed or even hinted at so far
they'll be the architects
of their own destruction and or will
also be set just a few years after the
events of obi-wan kenobi meaning that
characters from that show like moses
ingram's riva could appear as well cad
bain fenik shan the members of clone
force 99 all these characters and more
have the potential to show up in andor
especially since the show will cover
such a large swap of time
aside from rogue one which seems like
required viewing before going into andor
there are a lot of other star wars
movies shows and even video games that
will surely add context and depth to
your experience as it's set during the
same spot on the timeline and because it
also deals with the early rebel alliance
star wars rebels seems like the best
place to start while its tone is quite
different from what andor appears to be
going for it covers similar ground in
terms of the state of the empire public
sentiment regarding palpatine's regime
and the nature of the conflict against
it rebels is pretty long though so if
you're looking for some brief reviewing
materials to get you ready for andorr
there are plenty of other great stories
set during the imperial era star wars
the bad batch shows the very first stage
of imperial rule and it also spends a
lot of time in the seedy galactic
underworld that cassie and andor will
likely inhabit in his own series obi-wan
kenobi paints a pretty vivid picture of
the empire's power and its methods of
silencing rebellion while solo a star
wars story has some fun details about
what life looks like between star wars
revenge of the sith and star wars a new
hope of course if you'd rather play a
video game then watch a bunch more tv
star wars jedi fallen order is a great
place to start the next generation of
jedi
the empire will be after him
every live-action star wars streaming
series to date has been rated tv 14 even
obi-wan kenobi which is arguably the
darkest of the lot despite its grim
narrative and the downtrodden state of
the galaxy at the time andor will likely
receive the same rating at the end of
the day star wars is still a family
first franchise and disney probably
won't be compromising that stance
anytime soon it doesn't preclude and or
from handling serious storylines or
themes however from cassian's status as
a refugee to the oppressive rule of
palpatine's autocratic regime there's a
lot of rich meaningful and relevant
material for the show to pull from by
its very nature the series will deal
with the concept of radicalization and
what it takes to turn a seemingly
ordinary person into a martyr that's a
pretty heavy place to start from and if
andor pulls it off it could deliver a
powerful and nuanced star wars narrative
even with the tv-14 rating that means
that while the level of violence and
sexual content may be well within what
you'd expect for star wars the thematic
content may be a good deal more mature
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite disney plus shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]